high up in the himalayas you will find a
traditional nepali cheese that is known
as the hardest cheese in the world
it's so filling generations of nepalese
have relied on it during long days and
even longer journeys
[Music]
this great big story is inspired by
genesis
[Music]
mero nam denis
is a hardened block of cheese made from
local milk it's been a part of nepali
culture for centuries
it is an excellent source of protein and
provides much needed sustenance in
remote locations dinesh's chirpy will be
consumed within a year but if chirpy is
stored in a special yak skin it can stay
fresh for up to 20 years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is important because they eat special
grasses and herbs which contribute to
the chirpy's unique taste and
nutritional value
to make chirpy dinesh starts by heating
milk to 95 degrees fahrenheit
fat body
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
despite the hard work and long hours
dinesh and his family take pride in
providing this special cheese to their
community the next generation of
dinesh's family is still too young to
work in the family business but if they
decide to carry on the tradition he will
pass
[Music]
[Music]
you